fuori dalla routine un nuovissimo b
però l'idea del video di oggi vi è
venuta perché stavo ripensando tutte
quelle cose che prima di compiere 18
anni
immaginavo sarebbero successe una volta
computing panni quindi oggi ho voluto
proporvi 18 anni aspettativa realtà se
non avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al
canale cliccate sulla campanella vicino
al tasso d'iscrizione per ricevere una
notifica tutte le volte che pubblicherò
un nuovo video iniziamo subito tutti i
miei 18 anni affitterà un castello
enorme e farà un party che gossip le
foto è proprio la festa dell'anno non
vedo l'ora
amo ma tra una settimana il tuo
compleanno i tuoi 18 anni che non mi
lascia stare
ha già organizzato non organizzato nulla
perché i miei genitori non vogliono
farmi fare la festa nel castello perché
dicono che costa troppo non vogliono
farmi fare la festa discoteca perché
hanno paura che ti devo dire andremo al
pub e ci verremmo due birre
l'importante è stare insieme no appena
compirò 18 anni cambierà tutto i miei a
smetteranno di trattarmi con una
ragazzina in primis ma posso fare quello
che voglio
finalmente farò parte del mondo degli
adulti non me ne frega niente io quella
festa ci vado perché ho 18 anni faccio
quello che voglio ok finte vivai fatto
questo tetto fai quello che ti dico e
capita
quando compiono 18 anni uscirò tutte le
sere da una festa all'altra questa casa
sarà un albergo a mollo già detto anche
a chiara e stasera esco ma vi avviso già
non posso fare tardi quindi mi
raccomando non insistete come lo sapeva
il lavoro devo pure più il bar ti pare e
non posso anche bere o negativo libri h
ma figurati
[Musica]
e poi quando compirà 18 anni ovviamente
prendono la patente e una volta preso la
patente mi comprerò un mattino il
porterò in giro tutti i miei amici amori
sono pronta ci sono ma dai ma passati a
prenderlo per la stronza lo so che devo
prenderla inchiesta tra eta patente
perché tutto tempo lo sai si giuro che
domani vada iscrivermi promesso
stavolta lo faccia davvero
e poi troverò un bel lavoro e potrò
togliermi tu e gli sfizi che voglio
viaggi esotici borse firmate scarpe
costose no vabbè questa borsa è pazzesco
la voglio da li faccia questo regalo
vediamo quanta posta ma siamo pazzi
questi solidi guadagni in un mese lavoro
no non posso devo metterli da parte
non li metto mai da parte le comprava
mai niente posso finalmente dire addio a
tutte quelle paranoia da ragazzina e sì
perché a diciott'anni diventi più sicura
di te stessa del tuo potenziale della
tua bellezza attiri molti più uomini e
finalmente dirò addio a tutte le ore
passate a guardare il cellulare
aspettando il messaggio del ragazzo che
mi piace
adesso mi scrivi
un 2 3 che non mi scrivi maledetto cosa
ti ho fatto il male è uscito con me così
per passare il tempo non te ne frega
niente vero
mia mamma e poi la smetterò di sognare e
sì perché al 18 anni i sogni sono molto
più realizzabili nel giro di due tre
anni diventano milionaria come minimo
alla fine sono ancora giovane posso
aspettare a diventare milionario
vai a 40 anni avrò la mia azienda e farò
imprenditrice ed inter o mineraria
oppure presa alta siamo purtroppo
arrivati alla fine del video spero che
vi sia piaciuto e che vi siate in
qualche modo ritrovati
fatemi sapere con un commento qui sotto
se avete già compiuto 18 anni può non
gli avete ancora compiuti e seguitemi su
tutti gli anti social facebook instagram
ei tic toc
io vi mando un bacione ci vediamo al
prossimo
[Musica]